[Applause]
[Music]
high-speed train is one of Japan's icons
as it should be
Japan was the first country in the world
to bet with certainty on this technology
you see in order to understand the
origin of its high-speed rail network
popularly known as the Shinkansen we
have to go back to the 1950s
[Music]
at that time the general opinion was
that the railroads were becoming
somewhat obsolete a technology that
would sooner or later succumb to the
arrival of new highways and errands
[Music]
Oliver one men Shinji so go presidents
of the National Railway Company changed
the course of transport history
[Music]
his personal effort to develop a railway
that could compete with air routes not
only got the Japanese authorities decide
with him and his project it also ended
up shaping a high-speed rail system that
for the last five decades has been the
most advanced on the planet
in 1958 the government gave the green
light to the first high-speed line which
would connect the country's two largest
cities Tokyo and Osaka it began
operating in 1964 just in time for the
first Tokyo Olympics and ended up
costing 400 billion yen almost five
percent of the country's entire GDP for
that year
now despite such a huge investment the
truth is the project was overwhelmingly
successful in less than three years it
surpassed a hundred million passenger
mark more than 1 billion people used it
during the 1970s
[Music]
since then the Shinkansen Network hasn't
stopped growing today Japan's a
high-speed railway is owned by
profitable private companies its network
covers almost 3,000 kilometers and
transports more than 400 million
passengers every year
thanks to Japan's enormous success the
high-speed dream has become the
obsession of governments and politicians
across the planet and from every point
on the political spectrum socialists
conservative centrists everyone has been
tickled by this trend however outside of
Japan if we talk about high-speed
there's one country that stands out
above the rest
[Music]
it may come as a surprise but this time
we're talking about Spain the Spanish
high-speed train the our day has become
the jewel of Spanish infrastructure the
army has become a source of national
pride
it's strange to hear an electoral
campaign that doesn't mention it and
it's one of the few public policies that
generates a huge consensus among every
political greetin drove a case a rod
press pentose kilometres pereira
Engan shoe international por ESO
cerebral artery los zetas paniolo
celebrate los lagos de lifespan
yamadharma however hold on a second
because what has the other really
achieved for Spain has it really been so
successful and should other countries be
copying the Spanish model well in this
video you know answer all of these
questions
otaku sucks a penny located in a van an
ambitious bet first of all we need to be
clear about what a high-speed trainers
and what it is not you see in general
and according to the definition set out
by the international railroad Union
high-speed train is a railway whose
operating speeds can surpass 250
kilometers or 155 miles per hour of
course this is just the lower range in
the countries that have opted for this
type of infrastructure maximum speeds
can already exceed 300 kilometers or 185
miles an hour I mean they surprise you
but the Spanish high-speed network is
one of the most significant railway
networks on the planet in fact the ratio
between the number of kilometers built
or under construction and the number of
inhabitants is the highest in the world
neither Japan South Korea nor China
surpassed Spain we're talking about 80
kilometers of high-speed track per
million inhabitants check this out
[Music]
as if instead of the population we take
territory as a reference that country's
surface area Spain still remains in one
of the top positions taking third place
in this case it only ranks behind Japan
and South Korea
[Music]
in recent decades Spain has built a huge
high-speed network networks that
currently covers more than 2,800
operational kilometers with a further
800 kilometres under construction as you
can imagine building this huge network
it wasn't exactly cheap though the
Spanish government's investments in this
infrastructure already exceeds 58
billion euros a fortune that Spain has
funded like taking out loans
as a quick side note here the influence
of this Spanish project doesn't remain
exclusively in Spain
allow me to explain that well thanks to
the government's huge investment today
many Spanish companies are doing big
business they've basically managed to
develop technology that they're now
selling throughout the world
[Music]
for example the high-speed lines that
are being built in countries such as
Saudi Arabia or as Becca Stan have been
developed with the help of these Spanish
companies
[Music]
yes that's right even miss Becca Stan
perhaps the most remote country in the
world has climbed onboard the high-speed
train it's an international trend but at
this point the question we really have
is this can such a huge public
investment be justified because it helps
a few private companies do increase
their competitiveness but more about
that are there later first we need to
know where this story began so listen up
[Music]
Spain's golden year 1992 is a year that
will be recorded in the memory of
Spaniards for decades
Batya Spain swept the board by securing
every major international event Madrid
was chosen as the European Capital of
Culture Barcelona hosted the Olympic
Games and and Seville organized one of
the most ambitious Universal exhibitions
in recent decades in that year Spain
seemed to be king of the hill it was
precisely for that reason of the
socialist government at the time and by
Felipe Gonzales decided to take
advantage of this crowded calendar to
give Spain's international image a bit
of a makeover the country has presented
self as a modern thriving prosperous
country and to achieve that high-speed
trains were one of the government's best
bets
but there was a problem and maybe in
noticed Asst Barcelona the other great
cultural Spanish city along with Madrid
was hosting the Olympic Games and
Seville Andalusia capital is hosting the
expert
[Music]
so which city would take the lead which
train line would have priority would it
be one that connected Spain's two
economic powerhouses or one that would
connect the capital to the south one of
the country's most economically
depressed areas
perhaps the fact that the president of
the government was from Sibel law audit
and Alicia was a stronghold of the
Socialist Party it was more of a
deciding factor than the economic
exploitation criteria you know how
politicians are the fact is they're
finally after an investment of just over
5 billion euros in today's value what I
pulled the 21st 1992 the first are they
line between Madrid and Seville has
inaugurated
[Music]
and since then yabai has not stopped
growing financed by the spanish taxpayer
and by europeans who have contributed
millions if not billions in grants to
Spain from the European Union
[Music]
[Applause]
the fact is that it's been almost 30
years since the line was first
inaugurated more than enough time to
review the facts so how successful it
has Spain's high-speed project beam well
you know arts Houston rather Madrid we
have a problem Spain's experience has
been very different from Japan's so
let's take a look a flightless bird
[Music]
la is a faithful reflection of how
politicians often perform results are an
afterthought Spain's high-speed train
has grown a lot in extension of
infrastructure but not so much in
passenger volumes the result is that
today the Spanish high-speed network is
one of the most underused networks in
the world
[Music]
the network is used so little that its
profitability report is plagued with
many red numbers in fact the company
that manages the infrastructure loses
hundreds of millions of euros every
single year just maintaining and
operating the network currently there
isn't a single line that can be
justified from an economic perspective
the are they high-speed railways
especially though is designed to go over
300 km/h are very expensive to build and
very expensive to maintain and the
results as you can see should make
Spanish politicians blush with this data
in hand it's clear that no line in Spain
will ever be profitable according to
studies made by independent foundations
such as for DES and none of Spain's
high-speed networks beneficial not even
if they factor in social profitability
that is to say even if they save time on
traffic jams or displacements not even
when you count that are they properly
in fact some of the lines even have
negative social impact returns it's all
pretty crazy
[Music]
and if we include financial data money
that goes in and out the cold hard cash
then most of the lines will not only
never recover the investments made they
won't even cover their operating costs
[Music]
in other words this is a hole that
swallows tens of billions of euros and
Spain is going to have to keep paying
this for decades and that's not even the
worst of it the worst part is that many
of the lines that are currently under
construction will have an even more
disastrous future
[Music]
let me explain an the most attractive
lines have already been built and now
this infrastructure is being taken to
regions that don't have the basic
characteristics that a high-speed train
requires that is areas with high
population density high economic
activity and high purchasing power
Spain's arm a network is expanding
towards territories that don't meet any
of these criteria so future losses of
the network are just going to be much
greater a high-speed railway as Japan is
shown can be useful infrastructure but
only if it's approached with a rational
economic set of criteria otherwise it
can create a huge hole in the public
coffers the heavy burden on current and
future taxpayers
[Music]
while it's true that public
infrastructure can help create wealth if
it isn't executed based on feasibility
criteria it can have the opposite effect
what is good for a politician's campaign
isn't necessarily good for the citizens
and in this case things are they is a
prime example
[Music]
enormous investments in the alley
network has led Spain to neglect lines
used for moving goods but the positive
impacts on both the environments and the
competitiveness of Spanish companies
would be improved by replacing the
transport of goods by Road and bringing
it back to rail however instead what we
find a news stories like this one Spain
the new country that moves the least
Goods by train the Spain only moves 1.4
percent of its goods by train in fact in
the u.s. at the bottom of the list
barely beating countries like Luxembourg
Ireland or Greece it was quite a mess
really so why do politicians keep
focusing so much on high-speed rail well
I guess that's just because opening new
lines is pretty popular anyway that's
the reality of the Spanish high-speed
network but now it's your turn what
forms of transport do you prefer and
what do you think of high-speed trains
but leave your answer in the comment
section below and I really do hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always see you in the
next video
[Music]